people who watch vice laugh like this a
lot when you say something not true like
that they think it's not true they go
like this they left like this okay and
then they [ __ ] underhandedly slam
this [ __ ] out of you and nobody even
gets that they're slamming you except
for other people watch vice okay yeah if
that's how you think sure but what about
feelings that's what they do
people watch vice I always go like this
sure okay yeah I understand but what
about feelings what about girls with
short hair in their feelings so yeah
vice is you know always trying to expose
[ __ ] sometimes they expose [ __ ] that
doesn't even need to be exposed to like
lemons
what the [ __ ] on Vice lemons the guy's a
girl we talk to a lemon um and I sat
down with a lemon the lemon just on a
[ __ ] in front of a computer on a
keyboard just to see what the daily life
a level Emin actually is lemon just
sitting there for [ __ ] 12 seconds and
then a girl with [ __ ] oversized
glasses and a ponytail is like so and
she's wearing a flannel to make her or
makes a rope order so lemon so how do
you feel being just in a society cut to
the lemon just sitting there
do you just ever feel pressure to be
juice yeah you know I feel like I don't
know sometimes in my relationships go
sour sebat joke but that's what it is
dude that's vice bro i sat down [ __ ]
i sat down there was sitting down dude i
sat down with somebody who loves
painting just to see what their effects
are on society so painter yeah do you
ever feel like you're in a society
that's what they're always asking how do
you feel like being in a society well
you know in society I just feel like you
know painting has to be you know more
accepted because if it
not then we're in a society that's not
accepting things and then it's like what
kind of society are we in I sat down to
fart with a chef
[Laughter]
so your advice we sat down with the chef
that's riddled with tattoos all over
their arms because we've decided what's
a chef to do in a society so chef
society
so basically society here's what it is
so girls with short hair Society and we
wanted to just basically see what it was
like society and if we didn't then
there's no way I could cook crab cake
Society he farted then I farted my
glasses got bigger and I threw up
everywhere and it was normal um anyway
dude [ __ ] Vice is always exposing
[ __ ] doesn't need to be exposed you know
but it's cool I guess you know they the
one time they did were like there's a
stand-up culture in a garage and they
interviewed these guys doing stand-up in
a [ __ ] garage hey it's nothing
hey get out and part cars they're the
underground culture of stand-ups not
being accepted got in the club they
don't feel accepted so they started
stand-up in a garage good and everyone
that were like chairs set up in the
garage where the car should be and
everyone laughs everyone [ __ ]
everyone outside of comedy clubs that do
stand-up the outside of comedy clubs
everyone laughs like this ha ha ha like
they're [ __ ] Vince Vaughn on ritalin
dude
get out I know so many people are gonna
be upset but like whatever dude let's
just as hilarious that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
hilarious dude we caught up with this
underground stand-up comedy brigade
they just stand up in a forest they have
pointy ears cuz they're [ __ ] gnomes
but they're accepted and everyone laughs
like I did I did a what happened I did a
stand-up in one of those [ __ ] things
once and everyone was laughing like that
and I was like dude you're not even
really [ __ ] laughing and whatever you
know hey do you honestly do it wherever
the [ __ ] look here's the other thing to
do it wherever the [ __ ] you want I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm just making fun of it
you know there's stand-up comedy shows
in a [ __ ] laundromat you know do it
if you get a people there and they want
to pay and if they feel good paying and
they feel like they're supporting then
who gives a [ __ ] dude I don't want you
to come to my show to support I want you
to come to my show cuz you want to laugh
that's what I want people are like yeah
you got a support live comedy dude come
to laugh support somebody with cancer
come to my show to laugh but whatever
whatever makes you feel good at the end
of the day whatever makes you feel good
do it if you want to do a show for a
bunch of [ __ ] guys that sound like
Vince Vaughn on [ __ ] paid killers
then do it anyway your advice we caught
up with a [ __ ] turkey with glasses on
it shit's so Turkey do ever feel like
[ __ ] in a society very cool guy with
tattoos on his arms so we caught up with
a bunch of turkeys in Iraq and they made
actually a great point that I